vous avez bossé à la criminelle sans et
marthe leurs cieux même quand ils sont
morts et nous regardent ils veulent des
réponses est mort ou pas besoin de
réponses mans sonore
mon petit gars étaient allongés dans le
froid dans la souffrance pendant des
heures un personne qui a fait ça court
toujours
centaurus croire continue de la jouer
discrète si on demande ce que tu foutais
dans ce parc tu dit qu'ils étaient pour
le boulot c'était un accident un flic
blu est un gamin noir ça existe pas les
accidents
[Musique]
jeune noir de 15 ans laissé pour mort au
bord de la route tout le monde s'en
cogne de brent butler la vie de ce genre
de gamin n'est pas la priorité notre vie
[Musique]
m
suit un flic qui fait son travail et ça
consiste à pinces et d'autres flics je
vais pas devenir flic pour enfreindre
les règles je vais le faire je vais me
dénoncer
pour fliquer
toi et moi y'en a pas beaucoup des
communaux et on doit veiller là sur
l'autre ans
réfléchis un peu au genre de père que tu
seras te retient les barreaux
s'arrêteront pas
jusqu'à ce que tout témoignage les
mettre derrière les barreaux
[Musique]
il est possible qu'on ne sache jamais
ce qu'ils puissent savoir ce qui s'est
passé si dieu
c'est mieux qu'à renverser mon fils et
qui va laisser pour mort
c'est un homme qui a fait ça
[Musique]